this episode brought to you by Stardust
fan sharing video reactions to movies TV
and trailers also brought to you by
skill share classes taught by expert
practitioners for your career or for
your passions my god I didn't think you
needed to travel to another dimension to
prove your love of Christmas well this
is said to be the dimension that loves
Christmas the most I had to let my love
for this holiday just join them all
nobody loves Christmas more than me
today my god we may have missed one
the west of the Christmas it has to be
there's only one way to defeat
let's text my ass
[Music]
my god it's the Christmas tree my god
it's doubled in size
oh my god I thought this was gonna be a
challenge my god she's gonna breathe
presence on us Yuletide chainsaws clever
girl
she's spitting gift back bullet tennis
genius bitch it's just I wanted to get
bows so small no she's gonna finish this
off with a holiday flamethrower just
like on my Amazon wishlist
baby you messed with the wrong holiday
[Applause]
I think we should stop trying to top
ourselves every year with Christmas
greetings getting a little out of
Hampton mm-hmm
I think nothing was pregnant so we get
to live with that
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well as
many of you know I've reviewed what I
considered the worst Christmas special
ever the Christmas tree with its lack of
effort caring and complete disinterest
in everything Christmas it was by far
the worst Christmas special I had ever
seen but the internet set hold my beer
and apparently found a Christmas special
even worse that is supposed to be rap
city street kids believe in Santa
[Music]
getting a reputation as the food fight
of Christmas specials this CD
abomination aired once in 2002 and then
never aired again
yeah 2002 to give you an idea the show
we boo came out in 1994 and every week
had this quality to
[Music]
[Applause]
this is eight years later and aired once
they look more like the repo character
sex dolls than anything from an evolved
art form but thank you
shitty low-budget project makes shitty
low-budget shit the voice cast is
anything but low-budget it includes Luke
Skywalker Mark Hamill Princess Ariel
Jodi Benson princess Belle page O'Hara
Azula
great de lisle Black Power Ranger Walter
Jones mad TV's Debra Wilson and even
Bart Simpson Nancy Cartwright who also
has a producing credit on it a goddamn
producing credit did did everyone forget
this guy except a lot of life how did
this happen how did this make it to air
how did they get all these people
involved well surely there must be
something that there must just be
something anything God am I wrong or did
I have my soul horrendously sucked out
of me later
miss you this is rap city street kids
believe in Santa Oh South Park's
animation somehow managed to get cheaper
[Music]
yeah
music by I'm totally dan the element
everybody I'm totally danny elfman thus
we see one of our main characters
walking home it was this week before
Christmas that I'm talking I spent the
day shopping with my family walking no
don't be alarmed by the red that you're
seeing it's just your eyes bleeding from
watching the animation fear not you
don't get used to it this render that
didn't quite make it to the recycling
bin his name Ricky he's just dropping
some mad hits on his way home from
school I been a good boy you leave here
you better know it
you ready Santa Claus to start decking
the halls with gifts and yes eager
viewer I know is dying to ask she does
wrap all throughout the entire special
it's putting a cold the honey I know
she's into money I'm a decorating master
no one is faster Smith he's small and
round he's closest to the ground one two
three is all I see if you want to know
what you can trust
is that Santa believes in us I've been
told just tell me if you give trust me
there's no forgiveness hey look he
leaves no footprints in the snow
that's a detail I'm surprised they left
out after snapping his neck from looking
up he gets the smile of a serial killer
looking at all the toys in the store one
two three and no more oh he was looking
down at the animation budget actually
it's higher than I expected he
eventually goes home to look at his
teddy bear his mom gave him this bear
cuz of love so he'll give this bear cuz
of love I have no idea what that means
but that is literally the dialogue mama
you gave me this bear cuz of love so
I'll give this bear cuz of love
don't worry though the visuals explain
it better
[Music]
[Applause]
well that cleared everything up the next
day he goes to school a school that
misspelled the word excellence isn't
that a friggin metaphor you can't spell
like so much you can't achieve
excellence not too easy inside the
school I guess this is going on Kaname
schedules me for my own hair lady
Dana cold duck baby dinosaur anyone I
was getting a feeling this was a
student's final project for an intro to
3d animation class when the head of
great big F on it I would give it some
extra fluff
I guess the pressure to buggy is just
too much for me to resist you know the
animation so bad I'm seriously debating
whether or not that's supposed to be a
scarf or its lips go on Ricky's gonna
decorate the tree let's just see what
Ricky rhyme master can do it's actually
impressive how much that voice doesn't
match I think it actually took effort to
get that wrong maybe the only ever put
into any of this didn't your mommy teach
you to share
I mean make no mistake everybody in this
special should sound like
but that still seemed particularly off
I'm exaggerating master the one is
faster don't you know I'm a Christmas
tree blaster hmm those Ryan's are pretty
revolutionary however have you thought
about considering I'm a blood ugly team
made of Microsoft Paint
Harry's shit covered tampons that'll
make your ass faint just drop it from
the heart they go to their homeroom
taught by a malfunctioning Hall of
Presidents animatronic now sit down
please we can't they don't know how to
animate that yet
oh I'm not kidding they never do sit
down time passes and they're already
standing before recess it really was too
hard to animate them sitting down except
the creepy random adult who seems to be
sitting there stunk the whole time he
just likes to watch remember come in
promptly at the Bell teacher don't you
worry be right back in her so my lip
movements will be awfully blurry oh I
take it back sitting down isn't the
hardest thing to animate it's circles
goddamn circles the first thing you
learn to animate in CGI class but look
at them it looks like flat cutouts then
even the flat cutouts don't have the
shape of a full circle no one's Tecna
Smith man
I'm gaining on you smithy right after
we're done reenacting roads on the bow
of the Titanic
we're so alive whoa this reeks
I want waves not ice to bring steaks on
ice that's sad moment you realize they
could have made a superior movie by just
playing The Sims and talking over it I
think the deluxe edition will come out
about now but one of the boys named
smithy is really attached to a sandwich
that equals development now if you focus
any longer on this sandwich we're gonna
start making phallic connections you
already are aren't you bad news
Barrington get him away from me get him
away from me that means he likes you
that's the same school I'll Franken went
to this is such a great time of year
miss Farmington hello sir I hope you had
a really really happy holiday why thank
you the name Morgan Freeman bought
destroy you all with laser arms oh I
mean uh
happy holidays I know that my family is
just going to spoil me rotten to the
core I as it's been another wonderful
year in the Farmington House oh yes
[Music]
I want my I 1 by I 1 by m60 ok children
I wish you all a wonderful holiday
now please clean up your area before you
leave and don't forget to blink please
try to blink at least once over the
holidays yeah yeah yeah
Madge the maxi pads have taken fly it
again women problems am i right ladies
I guess those skills come later ah now
it's time to play what pops up very
frequently in this special drunk face or
kill face yeah that's a really valid
point so 13 minutes into this 40 minute
special and you notice something missing
it starts with Pete and its plot there
is no plot nothing seems to be going on
aside from us trying to figure out if
this was a troll or a mob front I'd
strangely have respect if it was both
finally the poorly rendered wheels of
storytelling are in motion as Ricky
gives Nicole his teddy bear
Merry Christmas Nicole have you lost
your mind are you purposely trying to
embarrass me
I can't even exchange this nasty old
thing which is why I'm still holding on
to it
anti sentimental purposes you might be
smart with books but you sure are stupid
I give you a real gift and you don't get
it
you know I'm not gonna lie I really
thought parappa the rapper his origin
story would be more interesting than
this hey brat who do you think you are
treating people the way you do perhaps
we should discuss this more on the ruins
of peaches castle from Mario 64 this is
so great
I know you like this stuff Nicole don't
particularly that girl's hair looks like
Chewbacca's butt cheeks is this all just
another life day tradition I'm gonna
wish I didn't know about what do you
think Santa will bring you this year you
still believe in Santa Claus eat human
brains after turning your scene into
binary code Nicole talks with her mother
about what a good kid she's been all
year you know I'm the bestest kid in the
world mommy I know you are and I'm the
luckiest mom in the world so lucky
ultras d materialized in the next shot
if she's been raptured there's still
hope it could happen to the rest of the
cast
oh yeah we're almost halfway through the
special makes sense to have our first
song I know Ricky's technically rapping
but that's in the context of the story
it's something he did for fun if they
acknowledged he was doing it this is an
actual full-blown musical number in that
it fully blows to witness any of it I'm
so glad her parents got that wallpaper
from free downloadable textures org it's
so hideous even the snow tried backing
away from it yeah straight-a student I
hope you enjoyed this amazing
choreography because there's over four
minutes of it left that's how long this
song is if you ever sick of let it go
just remember you can be listening to
mashed potato heads from Rap City stray
cats especially where only one kid
laughs oh and all his raps combined
still equal half the time of this one
song I really don't want to look at URI
Sublette enough in fact I think we all
need a break to look at something more
pleasant something is gonna hurt our
eyes a little less so if you'll excuse
me I'm gonna go look at the Sun Oh
[Applause]
you
[Music]
here we go Stardust presents two of the
three funniest reactions to rap city
street kids believe in Santa
[Music]
everything
you
what the fuck nostalgia critic why
didn't you encourage me to watch this
special I mean I thought that the
Christmas tree was bad but this this is
just insane the animation horrible the
story horrible the voice-acting
actually kind of okay and you know why
because it's got some voice acting
legends in it are you kidding me I mean
like Jodi Benson Nancy Cartwright page
O'Hara
Mark Hamill what the fuck just download
the Stardust app at the link below and
you too can see my latest reactions
including Avengers infinity war the
disaster artist and yes rap city street
kids be sure to follow us at nostalgia
critic and be sure to stay tuned after
to see who is the funniest one as well
as how you can be in the next episode
you suck that's not true I love you but
I'm sure you suck at something well for
example I suck at making a gif I know
that should be like the easiest thing
for an Internet person to do but I never
figured out how to do it but thankfully
whatever you suck at there's probably a
class for it on Skillshare this is an
online learning community with more than
17,000 classes in design photo and more
they have every kind of class you can
imagine you want draw your friend like a
Disney character you can you wanna learn
how to write comedy you can or if you're
an idiot like me and you want to do
something simple like make a gift they
even have a class for that if you get
their Premium Membership you can get
unlimited access to all of them you can
improve your skills unlock new
possibilities and just do the work you
love an annual subscription is less than
ten dollars a month making it one of the
best deals you can find for online
education and since they're sponsoring
this video the first 500 people to click
on the link below get their first two
months free to try out whatever you
don't know you can learn it here and for
a great price
click on the link below to try your free
trial today anything you want to learn
is just a click away
[Applause]
inclusion Irma is upset about there
being no Santa Claus and decides to ask
when her dad is getting back with the
tree when's daddy coming home soon right
after he picks up the Christmas tree
come on it's Christmas what a help eyes
a tree Christmas Day I guess I shouldn't
complain they did finally master the
incredible art of sitting down though
maybe not I think they just melted into
the ground a little bit yeah
knowing the special that seems very
probable Ricky goes to mail some letters
when one of them to Santa falls out
which confesses how much the bear he
gave to Nicole meant to him Nicole sees
it and starts to read even Nicole gave
him a special bear that Mommy oh dear
Ricky's pencil not render enough to keep
all the letters on that paper one of the
Rings from superman 64 mean well Ricky
talks with his great grandmother you
just got it I'm sorry could you say that
again just for a bit it will come back
to that when we move on to the next
sentence see let it go let it feel every
time a minute of this place a Pixar
animator kills himself am I really
seeing this every time she talked it's
like hearing a dolphin free from the
Necronomicon this can't be real oh well
let it go oh wait wait I got it it's
backwards speech if you take the audio
and reverse it you can hear what she's
actually saying go ahead let's try it
but you just got you I'm recording this
dialogue at the Pentagon where they're
holding Jesus he's still alive and he
has plans plans the government doesn't
want you to know about the answers are
in the Christmas special it's filled
with clues that's why none of it makes
any cat damn sense we watch the special
to find the truth
we watch the special to find the truth
oh yeah so Nicole looks in the dumpster
for the bear she threw out the poor
little princess is turned into a garbage
man did you like our attempt at a
threesome there they don't find it but
smithy hears that the cleaning man keeps
some of his garbage in the basement I
love creeping out creepy girl what did
he do that was creepy oh he merely
existed that explains everything
bunny smithy how was that basement what
are we watching it from the worst yet
somehow also best and nighttime goggles
do they belong to that guy from the desk
[Music]
now I know what I did wrong
this special came with a strip of acid
and I forgot to take it whoa now this is
gonna make sense yeah no it's still
awful it just looks like I'm watching it
in the matrix now they decide to go to
the junkyard but it looks like it's
guarded by dog ducks they come from the
upside down and somehow they CGI looks
even worse now what are you gonna do
listen if he has an idea for how to get
them off their bags Wow wonder he held
onto that sandwich it's Zardoz
the same which lands on the bullies and
the turd geese chase after them finally
allowing the kids to find the bear here
this was a gift for you but doesn't it
mean a lot to you yes and so does
friendship
[Music]
taught rest I can remember you Robert as
a little boy I remember one early
morning my sister brother and I running
down the stairs we thought that Santa
Hana grandma died get the shovel and to
my surprise they are right on our porch
set brand-new bison we really should be
digging her legs have already left this
world the rest of our can't be far
behind
hi sweetheart I understand you can use
you can see there's eyelids I am NOT a
computer programmer but how hard is that
how hard is it to give someone eyelids
how does he sleep how does a slave you
know nothing I'm not having a burning
dumpster fire of fun but shouldn't us be
over what else is left the kid got his
bare back that's the closest thing to a
story
so how's there still 10 minutes left Oh
princess as my good looks and your
spending habits oh I forgot we can't end
this caldron of nightmares without
revealing that's a joker isn't it calls
dad I bought you a new suit that's how I
get most of my suits
[Laughter]
put a big smile on pumpkin it's
Christmas and you know what that means
millions of dollars a day to finance my
happily even mystic lifestyle nothing's
too good for my princess and I've got
the credit card bills to prove it I'm
crazy enough to take on Batman but the
IRS no thank you
ah and the perfect little girl
little aren't you 13 help await your
enemy you could be 90 I got the most
beautiful wife and daughter and of
course they have the most handsome
husband and father
[Music]
Cummings yeah I got it run again
start the car Rickey opens up his gift
and finds it presumably the software
that made this movie Jana I think I see
something in the backyard melted horse
just what my sick fetish always wanted
well let my ghost legs dissolve through
my skirt to take a look so they all meet
up at one house because their families
are close and Ricky's great-grandma
gives her hex curse once more do you
know what Nicole I never stopped
believing in Santa she can talk now she
recovered from her stroke okay whatever
what does she have to say damn it
grandma
wait until you fully load before you say
anything or fully loaded which I think
you already are
oh look Satan Claus is trying to break
into our realm no luck today you shadowy
overlord there's more than enough evil
here I believe in Santa I am so proud of
you princess is it fun
and naturally we end on the kindness and
most comforting final line any Christmas
special has ever given us shut that door
[Music]
not even kidding that's the final line
shut that door wide end on that it's
beyond bizarre I so want to see other
Christmas specials end so abruptly shut
that door maybe Christmas perhaps means
a little shut that door shut that door
okay that's not the funniest part the
funniest part is after the end credits
where they actually advertise that the
rep city street kids will be back yeah
we're as popular as Superman so they had
to advertise their next adventure in the
credits just like his movies a Bunny's
tail huh well seeing how this came out
in 2002 and there's still no follow up
to it I'm just assuming they're working
really hard on it with all that extra
time put in I wouldn't be shocked if the
final product was this what the hell did
I watch rep City Street kids is awful
one of the worse it's lazy it's boring
it's hideous to look at but is it worse
than the Christmas tree well it's like
comparing Nickelback with Creed they're
both the worst but what's just gonna
annoy you more than the other personally
the fact that looks like more money won
into the production of the Christmas
tree which body never thought I would
say that seems a little bit more
insulting and how bad it is Christmas
tree is more memorably bad where this
one I feel like I could forget pretty
quickly
it's that boring but don't get me wrong
I can see how anyone can declare this
the worst holiday special
it is amazingly bad and incredibly
difficult to suffer through it just
depends on what offends you more but
whatever your tolerance trust me you'll
be offended by this giant piece of shit
you know what though it's got me
thinking and what's that critic about
what Christmas is really about really
this special helped you realize that
well in its total lack of creativity and
effort it did make me realize what's
really important family that is
important but there's something more
love that's also important but something
more even more than all those things
combined there is one thing that's more
important well what is it critic
[Music]
[Applause]
you
shut that door up up don't think we
didn't forget about the funniest
reaction to this piece of shit special
here it is
you also want to be in the next
nostalgia critic will download the
Stardust app and check out the Muppet
family Christmas this is a great special
you can watch on YouTube and we're
looking for your reactions to it just
click the link below to download the app
use this hashtag and will once again
pick the best three and put it in the
next video and be sure to follow us at
nostalgia critic to get all my latest
reactions
[Music]
[Applause]
see for the it will they call or give it
a different flavor for this deal
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out and this week we are doing
care org care is a leading humanitarian
organization fighting global poverty
they try to help so many people in
troubling situations particularly those
with little money they are at the heart
of cares community-based efforts to
improve basic education prevent the
spread of disease increase access to
clean water and sanitation expand
Economic Opportunity and protect natural
resources care also delivers emergency
aid to survivors of war and natural
disasters and helps people rebuild their
lives if you look at their site in their
YouTube channel you can see all the good
that they've done in the past and how
you can help them in their mission click
on the link below and see how you can
help a lot of great people get out of
poverty
[Music]
you